when did you guys stop
i was like beating our wives i guess
when did you guys stop sanitizing your
groceries if you did we were thinking
about stopping as of monday now that we
are both vaccinated
oh my goodness um i mean
here yeah we did yeah we were
careful about surfaces early on and then
it became pretty clear that surfaces
were not a major mode of transmission
yeah um for sars kobe 2
and so we stopped and you know i mean
people people who've been watching these
live streams forever will remember i had
a
rubric about cotton gloves that i could
wear when i was
out and then ditch them put them in the
wash as soon as i got home
basically a sacrificial layer i wore
surgical gloves at the market for
um a couple weeks yeah a couple weeks
um maybe a month or so back you know
march
march 2020 um and i put i bought a bunch
of copper tape
and i put put copper tape on our outside
um door handles because it's it's
anti-viral
um we never standardized our groceries
um but we um
you know we left packages in the garage
for 24 hours if they came if they
weren't
um yep if they if they weren't gonna
decay
um and we'd and we stopped putting you
know bags of groceries
you know for a while that you couldn't
use your own bags and so we wouldn't we
wouldn't bring bags and put them on the
counters we would only put them on the
floor and
yep and we were more diligent we almost
always
buy organic and so there's less of an
urgency from our perspective
of washing it because we're not washing
pesticide residues off of anything
of course some wise person at a farmer's
market says you should always wash
anything that grows lower than a bird
flies but that's right
those are my favorite uh vendors up in
the olympia
farmer's market yeah yep but anyway
the point is it quickly became clear
that this thing doesn't transmit by
fomite very frequently and so we stopped
being vigilant the irony
is that all these other things still do
right
we've got all these other pathogens out
there and so
i i would love for us not to lose track
of the fact that we have actually had
an arbitrary impact on all sorts of
other pathogens because suddenly we're
all now talking pathogen which we should
have been from the beginning
yeah and the fact is flu ain't no joke
right and to the extent that we can stop
being cavalier i mean it has
never it has never uh ceased to amaze
me at how we don't think
about the horrible impact if you have
the flu
and you're a little bit careless and you
get somebody sick and you cost
them you know however much health
right a solid week plus a bunch of later
right
presumably they age faster they suffer
intensely for
some fraction of a week yeah right
that's a that's a
huge disservice you have done them and
we don't put nearly enough into thinking
about how to protect people from that
and you know suddenly we're now all
conscious about how germs do and don't
move around but we're too focused on the
one germ
right yes the one germ is pretty
freaking important there are plenty of
things that spread by foam rights
there are plenty of things and so yeah
like you know public bathrooms like
at some point it's gonna be ridiculous
you're gonna feel
ridiculous being in a mask in a public
bathroom but there's a lot of stuff you
know public bathroom we've talked about
this before and
you know it's not pleasant but you know
public bathrooms don't have
toilet lids yep and a lot of stuff
sprays into the air
and what an easy way to protect yourself
just a little bit by
masking up in a public bathroom it's
true yeah i'm actually watching
with some horror i mean on the one hand
it's sort of reassuring because it's
normalcy
but i'm watching the handshake return
there was a year there where
we didn't shake hands well
there's that but to the extent that
there was a handshake it was like a
little funny every time you
bump somebody by the elbow on the other
hand
are we so sure we want to resurrect the
handshake
i'm not yeah you know jake you know
we do need to be able to touch people
sure but frankly and i i guess
you know some things do transmit by foam
right yeah
for years long before kovid i tend to do
you know an elbow or at least the back
of the hand to press elevator buttons
um you know elevators these are closed
spaces you just don't know who has done
what you know
right put their fingers where and then
touch that thing and i was actually in a
this is months ago now but in some
medical something um
and i got an elevator and a couple of
people got in with me so it couldn't
have been that long ago because for a
while it was like only one person an
elevator at a time right
um and it was a nurse and it turns out
her sister and i
and i asked them what floor and i
pressed it with my elbow
and they both just smiled big at me
under their masks i could tell
and the sister of the nurse said my
sister has been doing that since she was
little and she always knew she was going
to be a nurse
it's like yeah like that is going to
transmit some stuff if someone's sick
just touch that
and you touch that you might get sick as
it turns out you're not likely to get
sick with kova doing that
right possible but you're not right but
yeah how many other things are we
transmitting this way
and frankly i think handshakes are
suspect and
not necessary frankly i think a hug is
less dangerous than a handshake
that's a good news well i mean look a
handshake you know somebody has
touched a button right or they've gotten
sick and they've wiped their nose and
then you shake their hand and then you
wipe your eye and that's that
right and the point is that's a pretty
direct
route for pathogens to figure out yeah
um so anyway it's not that you know it's
not that i don't think the handshake was
doing something i know that it was i
mean evolutionarily speaking
you know it may be interchangeable with
a bow but
it's doing something right and you can't
just you know chesterton's handshake you
can't just get rid of it
but we should pay much closer attention
we are living in
much greater density than we were and
you know there's a lot there's a big
cost to be paid for not being careful
about this stuff
lovely heather and brett how are you
both we're so grateful for you
if someone with covet has been in our
home how long can it stay in the air and
on surfaces
we cannot find up-to-date information
anywhere
um i think we can do a pretty good job
of this for one thing yeah especially
uh statistically speaking it's very
likely
that you are in the northern hemisphere
because that's where people tend to be
um i mean it is yeah uh but anyway
hey it's the northern hemisphere it's
summer uh
do what we do open all your windows
turn on whatever fans anything that
increases air flow you can
i mean basically yeah in that case like
everything like air filters
fans windows everything yeah everything
um you know and
go outside after you know but the person
is asking how long until their home is
safe
well here's the problem okay
know that there's not very much
transmission uh on surfaces
does that mean it's impossible no it
can't be impossible is not
uh it's a standard beyond which you can
go ahead and clean the surfaces
well i would certainly clean you know
the few surfaces that are
likely that they contacted and likely
that you will contact
and basically it's a diminishing returns
problem but probably if you did nothing
of that sort
the services aren't where you would uh
contract the disease right it's in the
air
it stays in the air um
you can reduce that effect by allowing
diffusion to
purify your air more quickly the more
your air
the more the more surface area your
building has
exposed to the world where it's
exchanging uh the faster it will clear
um the you know
i guess the thing is it's the it's the
model that we were developing at the
beginning of this whole thing if
somebody
that turns out to be sick or that you
don't know and you think they may
have been sick or you're just simply
unaware you know if they spend a bunch
of time in some
room then that room is much more
compromised than any other place and
you know airing it out makes sense
staying out of it so that you know
things that have hung in the air have
time to settle
all of these things will help um but
well maybe that's that's just it yeah i
don't i think
at the very least it's going to be a
decay rate
issue and there comes a point at which
the
likely modes of transmission have
decayed
back so close to baseline that it would
be undetectable
yeah yeah we're not coming up with any
numbers but um
if you've got a lot of windows and you
open them all and there's any sort of
breeze at all
um you're gonna you're gonna have a
complete exchange of air
in not too many hours should be yep
you